it was one of flea bottom just like you
live below the street of flour how close
to the red keep way um Gianelli hey
youtubers is charlie welcome to my game
of thrones season 4 preview for ser
Davos he's one of the best characters on
Game of Thrones but because he's a minor
character we don't see him quite as much
he'll do a quick back story on how ser
Davos ended up with Stannis and how he
got knighted as well as some of my
favorite moments from the show so far
before talking about season four boilers
for everything that's happened on the
show so far and minor spoilers for
Brooks four and five so sir Davos
Seaworth is called The Onion Knight
that's his sigil and he chose it himself
someone didn't give that to him it's
kind of an inside joke between him and
King Stannis but I don't think Stannis
really gets the joke he was originally
the smuggler that worked in the Narrow
Sea and during Robert's rebellion he
helped smuggle in food to Stannis's army
Stannis was actually left behind when
Robert went to fight the crown so there
weren't really any soldiers to help so
they basically got shut up for almost a
year so Stannis in a rare moment of
gratitude night in sir Davos but not
without taking pieces of each of his
fingers off most of the food that he
brought to sandis included onions and
dried fish so thus he became The Onion
Knight so before we get to season four
let's talk about our favorite sir to
have those moments personally mine is
when he's in the dungeon beneath
Dragonstone with Gendry in season three
they have this really heartfelt bro
moment where they just talk about how
shitty their lives have been it's
basically like a my life is shittier
than yours kind of conversation note to
self if you ever moved to King's Landing
don't live in flea bottom what is he
going to be doing in season four now
that Stannis and Melisandre headed to
the wall and now that the showrunners
are actually changing a lot of things
from books four and five for the show
well you can think of Sir Davis's story
in book four and book five is kind of
like a Theon Greyjoy situation no he
doesn't get tortured within an inch of
his life and pieces of him don't get
sent to Stannis but he really doesn't
appear in book for that much he comes
back in book five the showrunners like
they did with Theon or basically going
to bring that story into season four so
you'll see a lot of season five things
if you've read that book happening in
season four if you remember at the end
of season three sir Davos basically
bargains for his life by telling Stannis
that I'll help replenish his army in his
fleet remember most of those soldiers
died in the Battle of Blackwater Bay so
Stannis really doesn't have much of an
hour
right now and he's headed to the wall
the sanest needs to find more ships and
more soldiers that takes them to white
Harbor but there are some starch
sympathizers there and turns out the
Lannisters have one of their sons so sir
Davos and actually gets thrown in the
dungeon in exchange for their son
socially demands that they kill sir
Davos the interesting thing here is is
that sir Davos actually ends up helping
the Starks in this indirect way not
directly he's not he's working for our
Catelyn Stark who obviously a very
unfortunate time in season three but he
does end up helping stark bannermen get
Rickon back but it's this side mission
that we probably won't see until season
5 it will actually take him up back to
where Stannis is so there's a good
chance that he could actually help
Stannis out in the battle with the
wildlings but the really interesting
thing about Game of Thrones is that
because the actual land mass of Westeros
is not super ginormous a lot of the
characters end up running into each
other again later in the story so it'll
be really interesting to see and I
totally think that sir Davos will
eventually get pulled back into service
with Stannis and Melisandre mostly
because the place where Rickon is being
held remember he's going to be sent to
rescue Rickon is actually right in your
Eastwatch which is basically where you
take ships when you're going to the wall
but let me know if you think that sir
Davos is going to end up helping Stannis
and Melisandre or if he's gonna take off
and go to the east remember he's been
serving Stannis for a long time he hates
mill Sandra and Stannis has been
crapping on him all of season three and
it probably continue to happen in season
four so he really doesn't have much of a
reason to keep serving Stannis but let
me know what you think either way
Halloween is this week and I thought
it'd be fun to do a game of thrones
halloween video since I'm so close to
30,000 subscribers so there isn't much
of a Halloween in Westeros they don't
have a lot of holidays the closest thing
they have is actually something honoring
the stranger so be sure to subscribe to
get that video i'll try and post it this
friday tonight i'll be posting my latest
episode of agents of shield and tomorrow
morning i'll be posting my latest
episode of supernatural so there's any
big questions you have about sir Davos
or anything the you thought was really
important that I didn't include in the
video be sure to write it in the
comments and we'll discuss off' I as
always if you really want to help me out
please like and share this video thank
you so much for watching you can click
here to watch all my other game of
thrones season for previews and you can
click here to watch my latest Walking
Dead video thank you so much I'll see
you guys tonight high fives